hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
aging is a part of everyday life it's
guaranteed to happen to everyone
eventually we all get old develop
diseases slow down and eventually die of
old age
we all understand it but what if we
actually don't understand it and what if
things didn't have to be this way what
if we could slow down the clock and even
turn it back well researchers are
developing ways to unlock the tools
within our own body to help us do
exactly that in this video we'll take a
look at something a little different
health regeneration
let's get into you are what will
ColdFusion TV
[Music]
these are two mice one looks young and
healthy the other decrepit and old but
these mice were actually born on the
same day in fact they're twins dr.
Sinclair at Harvard Medical School led a
team of researchers in this experiment
the goal was altering the epigenome in
the DNA in one of these mice so what is
an epigenome in short it's responsible
for coiling up and turning on and off
parts of a DNA string as required
depending on the parts of the DNA that
is turned on and off means the
difference between creating a skin cell
versus a nerve cell our DNA is
effectively the code which tells
ourselves what to be as we age
researchers believe that our DNA
epigenomes unravel and other parts that
weren't meant to be quelled becomes so
effectively our bodies begin to create
the wrong cells in the wrong places this
deterioration of epigenetic information
is what dr. Sinclair's team accelerated
in one of the mice therefore one Mouse
literally aged faster than its twin
aging is in fact something that our DNA
tracks very accurately and
quantitatively this is how it's done
DNA is made up of four different
components called nucleobases they are a
C T and G and they're paired together to
make the famous double helix structure
over the course of our lifetime methyl
groups which are just a carbon with
three hydrogen's begin to attach to the
C components of our DNA by measuring
your DNA through a blood sample or a
mouth swab scientists with the help of
AI can tell exactly how old you are
based on how many methyl groups you have
this is called the Horvath clock it's
extremely accurate and can even predict
when you'll die
this is a recent discovery and it's not
just an accurate measure of biological
age researchers believed that the clock
itself is part of the aging mechanism
hence physically being able to dial back
the hands of the clock could mean
becoming physically younger however this
appears to be one of many interconnected
mechanisms that control aging the
analogy is by dr. Sinclair is that our
epigenetic information is lost over our
lifetime much like a CD gets scratched
over time and begins to glitch the old
theory was that our DNA information gets
lost over time as we succumb to entropy
in the old theory the damage comes
through free radicals oxidization DNA
mutations and damage dr. Sinclair
believes that we should throw that
theory out it's not the loss of DNA
itself but the on and off switches on
our DNA so is there a way to polish our
genetic CD and get the information back
and if we push the reset button how many
times can we do it is there a limit well
there's some promising research being
carried out
[Music]
the doctor and his team were much more
interested in reversing the processes of
aging rather than inducing it what would
come after the initial mouse experiment
could prove to be a revolutionary step
again these are two mice on a treadmill
both at 20 months old the equivalent of
approximately 70 human years but one has
been treated with a chemical compound
known as nmn if he guessed the mouse on
the right you'd be correct treated mice
ran on average 430 meters compared to
the untreated control group which ran
240 meters as the experiments progressed
some peculiar things began to happen the
mice that we treated within a man they
just ran and ran and ran they actually
broke the little treadmill in my lab
because they ran so far and I get a text
from the researcher hey the machine
broke and I said check the software and
turns out software was written to stop
it three kilometers because my mouse had
run that far before that's long and
those are old mice don't forget these
are mice the equivalent of the
equivalent of a 65 year old human they
ran and ran around they didn't get
lactate build-up as much as didn't feel
tired these chemical compounds all help
increase something called nad levels in
the body
dr. Sinclair's research is trying to
link NID with ageing nad
is central to the metabolic system
helping carry electrons between
reactions within all living cells
Sinclair and his team are testing nad
boosting drugs on the elderly and hoping
to get FDA approval for yeast and
diseases in the next three years
other factors apart from specific drugs
that boost nad levels are natural things
such as exercise a good diet and even
fasting which dr. Sinclair practices
himself so to be clear living a healthy
lifestyle naturally boosts your nad
levels but it's the drug component of
increasing nad levels that is
potentially a game-changer however
there's understandably some controversy
around so-called
Fountain of Youth pills some saying
current research doesn't back up the
claims others using anecdotal evidence
to the contrary while there is evidence
to show that the use of compounds such
as M&M increase nad levels in the body
there still isn't concrete evidence that
nad levels increased longevity and human
trials are still ongoing there is
however a decline of nad levels with age
and this was the spark that turned
researchers to focus on nad as a
proponent of aging with time we will see
if the trials and Myers can be carried
over to humans
but this all doesn't end there another
interesting discovery which may be
fundamental to getting humans to be able
to regenerate their bodies is something
called the Yamanaka factors these are
named after the Nobel Prize winner dr.
Yamanaka he used these factors to
convert human adult cells into stem
cells effectively a blank canvas to be
used anywhere in the body dr. Sinclair's
team attached some of the in Monaca
factors to a benign virus and then
injected it into two mice the
researchers pinched an optical nerve in
the eye of both mice effectively
crushing it now young cells will
regenerate and heal themselves while old
cells will struggle some species even
have the ability to grow entirely new
limbs what if there was a way to find
the part of our epigenome responsible
for regrowing damaged or lost parts of
our bodies and then turn it on more on
this later back to the experiment the
effect of the emmenecker factor virus
can be seen the top image shows no
treatment and the cells don't regenerate
and fix themselves the bottom image
shows a treated Mouse the cells in this
Mouse actually begin to grow back
towards the eye and within 16 weeks they
repair entirely could this eventually be
a key to treating degenerative diseases
for example poor vision due to age
perhaps this technology could repair the
eyesight of the elderly and maybe even
injuries like spinal injuries it's
interesting to think about dr. Sinclair
explains that at least in mice
researchers know that they can
positively improve vision the cells that
were old began to wake up they begin to
remember that they are a photoreceptor
cell and not a half skin cell they are
measurably younger parts of their genome
that are meant to be on are turned on
and the parts that are meant to be off
are coiled up and even if this is true
just for mice it really is amazing we
find that with our reprogramming we can
make the nerves be just like a newborn
baby they grow back
and then we also tested on glaucoma
pressure in the eye we increased
pressure in the mouse's eye and they
lose their largely thir eyesight and we
can recover that and then we also a test
old mice that don't see very well and we
also seem to improve their eyesight
almost back to normal so what I I don't
think we'll be going to nursing homes
any time soon but what we are doing is
running a clinical trial on this and so
we're looking to do that in early 2020
and the clinical trial will be on people
with glaucoma or various eye issues the
plan is glaucoma first but it could work
for other damaged retinas as well even
broken spinal cords what we're thinking
of trying the ability to turn on or off
specific parts of the genome is a very
interesting proposition we can turn off
parts of our genes which may cause
genetic diseases
so in conclusion dr. Sinclair's work is
on the cutting edge of research into the
aging process while he doesn't claim to
have found the Fountain of Youth his
research is very promising and could
lead to some very inspirational outcomes
at the very least we could help improve
health for those later in life this
would give people a better quality of
life in their final decades but
interestingly it could also save
trillions of dollars in the long run as
there would be much less of a burden on
our healthcare systems but at best we
could unravel the secrets to our own
bodies discovering parts in our DNA we
never knew existed we could help reverse
diseases that are incurable today and
live longer and healthier too this field
is a rapidly evolving one and right now
is still in the research stage it will
probably be decades before this
technology if even possible will become
available for widespread use regardless
is still interesting to see how such new
fields of research are emerging of
course there should be some caution in
how we proceed when it comes to
modifying genetics but for increasing
nad levels at least that doesn't seem to
be much of a downside and that's
probably because nad is a natural
chemical that comes from a healthy diet
and exercise
if we do in fact get there this could
turn out to be one of the most pivotal
things the human race has ever done I'll
be watching this space with every action
we assume there's some negative
consequence or potentially negative
consequence right we always assume that
but it's not always right mmm so it with
the molecules that we've been testing
for years now like in a man we haven't
seen any downside just longer endurance
and protection so there isn't always a
downside to these things in fact if you
just think any man is replacing a
molecule that we lose over time as you
get older it's just becoming you know
it's fairly natural process no downside
exercising and dieting
I hope you enjoyed that video or at
least found it interesting if you're
interested in science technology
business or history feel free to
subscribe to this channel I'm sure
you'll find some interesting stuff on
here alright so my name is - gogo and
you've been watching cold fusion I'll
see you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion
it's me thinking